um and something that makes me happy as
a former NFL player I talk to the table
is not one but two CBS mornings
exclusives about what is considered to
be the NFL's most prestigious honor and
who's in the running last year the
Titans nominated Derek Henry for the
Walter Payton Man of the Year award he
is a powerful downfield running back one
of the best in the game but it's off the
field where he's putting in work
empowering Youth and giving back to the
people of his hometown Yulee Florida
recently he went back to his high school
his old high school and surprised the
football team with brand new Nike
sweatsuits ahead of their first Regional
playoff game and the CBS morning's
exclusive we can announce that Derek
Henry has been nominated for the Walter
Payton Man of the Year award for the
second year in the row something right
that's right and we spoke with him and
he shared what it would mean to win
it would mean the world to me
um at least something that you know kind
of dream of as a kid is
um being just of just being just as
effective off the field as you are on
the field so for me to win this award I
mean I would be very grateful and um you
know I never want to let let down what
you know the award stands for
and now another exclusive you are seeing
for the first time the full list of
nominees for this year's award some of
the names Dak Prescott Patrick Mahomes
Shaquille Leonard among others and don't
forget you can catch Derrick Henry and
the Titans here on CBS this Sunday along
with our Full Slate of NFL on CBS action
we kick it off with the NFL today at
noon Eastern so here's the thing about
the Walter Payton men of the Year award
the NFL hands out a ton of Awards as we
know but this one is such an honor
because it's not what you do on the
field it's what you do off of the field
and listen sometimes we get these
headlines that come out of sports
professional sports yeah but there are
more men and women in professional
sports that give back to their community
and for NFL players yeah this is that
one award where even in a locker room
full of men with eagles who make a ton
of money we tip our hat to that guy who
wins that award every single season
because it's a big deal then I'm gonna
pull for him then you like him oh he's a
great pull over here right I'm rooting
for as well nice